[Music]
so
hello you peoples yeah it's tuesday
you peoples you people yeah you know all
of you peoples
man i should have got some tea to drink
why don't you get some tea you can still
get tea hold on one sec
he's gonna go actually that's already
made sitting on my sit next to the bed
hurry up damn so unprofessional
just kidding but yeah so it's a kind of
a gloomy tuesday although
i like that weather he's like
complaining about it he's like no
funny a keem good sit by the pool maybe
but you know i like it when it's rainy i
don't give a [ __ ]
uh so yeah we went out last night to
memento mori so for a little sleepy
that's uh probably why
we had a good time though not a hell of
a lot of people there was a little bit
dead but
you know what are you gonna do um yeah
so
tom has been very excited to finally get
to talk about the mommy
because as i said i had heard i hadn't
seen it
but i had heard you know i knew a little
bit about what was going on with
universal in the dark universe and
everything like that
and i knew that it that that movie kind
of uh
squandered their plans for that so
i'd heard it wasn't good like i said the
trailer
you know what i was kind of like okay
yeah i can see where that's gonna go
but i don't know for some reason like
randomly tom was like i think i want to
watch it
like just a couple nights ago and i was
just like yeah why not
so we didn't have anything else to do so
so we watched it and we were talking
about it it's interesting because
um there you are you didn't take that
one i was talking about how
rainy it was and then i was just
starting to talk about the mommy but you
know
this tea is so good what kind is it
ginger yeah yeah maybe i'll get
something a little better yeah i just
got water
yeah okay so what were we saying oh i
was just talking about how
um i guess our opinions are kind of
divided on this one
yeah i've been saying this movie was
grim i i
i have to i have to disagree i like this
movie
i just did i didn't hate it but
it had a lot of problems you know what i
mean
when i saw the trailer for it like back
in 2017 when it came out
um i was like yeah i see how that's
going to go i see what direction they're
going with that
and i and it was exactly what i expected
it was essentially like uh like a
mission impossible movie or like
like the ethan hunt movies or whatever
with tom cruise in there just with a
mummy sometimes
yeah it was kind of like a bunch of you
know had a bunch of different stars in
it
um it had some it had some good
characters there were some good ideas
in it uh they're trying to you could
tell they were trying to make a like an
extended universe a bunch of movies
kind of reminded me of like
in in some ways it kind of reminded me
of like uh the underworld
movies and or maybe like yeah league of
extraordinary gentlemen kind of like
that yeah it
reminded me of that pretty strongly the
tone was kind of like a modernized
big action tent pole
flick kind of inspired by indiana jones
it had a lot of
[ __ ] indiana jones feel too but see
they already did
mummy movies like that with brendan
frazier back in the late 90s and those
were super fun
they didn't care because that's what
those were those were kind of like hey
fun indiana jones movies like for the
late 90s
and they were they were super funny and
like they had some super like the first
one was really good i think the second
was okay too but i think they started
like getting shitty after that
yeah but um but yeah it's like i i
really enjoyed those and i kind of feel
like they were trying to do that with
this but then they were also trying to
have a serious tone and then they were
also trying to do like a marvel
cinematic universe thing
and make it like an like a tom cruise
action movie and it just wasn't
working for me it just wasn't working it
seemed like it wanted to be well i
should note
that this movie and if you've seen it
this will not shock you
had five or six uh different
screenwriters on it and uh you can tell
yeah because it's going it's kind of a
mess it's it's kind of going in a bunch
of different directions
not sure what tone it wants to be not
sure what type of movie it wants to be
there's like some cool ideas in there
the visuals are cool the mummy looks
cool as [ __ ]
she's awesome yeah there needed to be
more money
for one thing and there needed to be
more egypt for another thing
yeah i guess i guess that'd be hard to
do there's a couple problems with it
that i noticed
first off the military they showed the
us army and the uniforms were just all
wrong
um they got it just the terminology that
they used was all wrong the equipment
that they had was just
pretty right and tom cruise was supposed
to be an army sergeant or something like
that and he's basically
out in the desert like looting
antiquities yeah that was weird too he's
just being an army sergeant
was he an ex-army sergeant or no i think
he i think they were implying that he
was still in or he was some kind of
special ops mission or they didn't
really make that real clear
why didn't they just make him an
archaeologist or something i i don't
know
i don't know i mean problem solved and
then who was his commander and why
didn't he have to report back to his
unit when all this was done i didn't
but i wasn't that's what i'm saying i
was just going i was not taking the
movie seriously at all
i was just watching it
[Laughter]
and just enjoying the crazy spectacle of
what they were [ __ ] doing
um that was one of the problems so
the portrayal of the us army was totally
inaccurate
just all the way down to just the
equipment and just how they do things
and
and and the uniforms it was all wrong um
the other thing that i didn't like about
it is that when that one scene when the
mummy chick
makes the big wave of sand go through
the city
you see like her face in it and they did
that already
in the other mommy movie yeah in the
brand of freezer ones
it was cool in the 90s and they i could
tell that they did that
just so they could put that in the damn
trailer yeah of course
it would that that scene was kind of
ruined by the face being in the sand it
would have been better if it was just
the sand
it had been a lot better yeah um so they
kind of went over the top
every now and then um the the egyptian
mummy chick she was hot man i liked her
i really liked the look of her i thought
that was like a cool character
really real goth kind of look you know
real pale with like magical inscriptions
in her and sometimes she was more
rotten she started off real rotten but
she got more and more
uh kind of human looking
as she drank people's souls she could do
some pretty cool [ __ ]
she had a whole backstory um it did
russell crowe appears and he turns out
to be he's [ __ ] dr jekyll
yeah and he's controlling mr hyde
with this drug that he takes to keep it
down
uh and he has he has a secret room that
he can go to that won't
won't let him out if you know what i
mean it's not a secret room but it's
just kind of like a
a tricked out headquarters he has so if
he uh
starts going mr hyde it won't let him
out the room and they showed him go hide
and i was like oh yeah that's [ __ ]
awesome
i i wanted more mr hyde i kind of feel
like and i was watching a bunch of other
videos about this this morning and this
one guy i can't remember what his name
is but he has a channel where he kind of
was breaking down
uh you know what went wrong with the
movie and he was like you know if they
want it he's like actually because the
dark universe
is a great idea and i actually would
have liked to have seen that
yeah um but just the way they went about
it was kind of [ __ ] up he said
you know if you're going to make you
know dr jekyll
kind of the the head of this underground
society like the talamasca or whatever
that's like fighting the monsters and
fighting evil
why didn't they open with his movie yeah
it's like because then you could have a
sympathetic character
that you could relate to and then later
because he's kind of like the nick fury
type of character right
and it's like and then you could have
expanded out because it's like that
it just seemed like because what he was
getting into too much in one movie yeah
what he was getting into was that
it's not you know the mummy movies as
much as i love the mummy movies and i
love like the boris old boris karloff
ones and stuff
but that it doesn't have like a specific
character he's not like
specific like dracula or frankenstein's
monster or anything like that he's not a
specific character
you know the mummy because they changed
him even like back in the 30s and 40s
they had you know there was in
hotep and then there was like the other
one that was uh charis or whatever he
was called
um and they had like mummy princesses
and stuff so there's not like a specific
character that you can latch on to in
the mummy
so it seems like with ones like mummy
um they should have probably done that
later on in the franchise
i thought it was a it would have been a
better idea to start with like a jekyll
and hyde movie
and then kind of like go out from there
because he was supposed to be the
central
right now um
i think it's badger the bad badgers
saying that the jekyll and hyde didn't
work for him
well the reason why it didn't work is
there wasn't very much of it and
uh you didn't really get to see
what mr hyde was all about he did when
he appeared
i liked him and i liked the slow
transformation into him over a few
sentence and he would say [ __ ] that i
was like yeah i was like yeah yeah
that's yeah i started agreeing with him
yeah that's right i know that i know
that feeling that's it
that's right um and now somebody else
asked uh
uh you know i thought all of tom
cruise's movies
were inspired by his journey yeah uh
yeah actually no no they're not um
it might as well have been yeah but not
they're usually not um the only one that
kind of was [ __ ] scientology inspired
was uh
it's like in battlefield earth and that
was called battlefield earth yeah
i've seen it twice all the time yeah
yeah i actually
i couldn't sit through it i i saw it
twice i liked it it wasn't even
it wasn't even so bad that it was
entertaining
it's like it was kind of funny at the
beginning because you know what the [ __ ]
am i watching kind of way but then i
started like dozing off
you know what i'm saying i kind of liked
it man
it had some good elements to it
yeah they [ __ ] that movie up it's
entertaining to watch though i thought
it was
because i know the story behind it yeah
you know i mean this is
l ron hubbard you know or inspired by l
ron
hubbard's work and then we're talking
about battlefield earth now i gotta stop
it but you know yeah why are you doing
it i don't know
then he's like yelling at me like i did
it
it's just obvious to me when you're
watching battlefield earth that the main
character in the story the savage guy
who gets brainwashed by the damn alien
computer
it's obviously it's obvious that they
chose that act because he looked just
like david miscavige
yeah that dude looks just like david
mcgowan he did yeah so that's who that's
supposed to be
yeah fourth throw down was that russell
crowe just playing himself that's what i
said i was like he's gonna throw a phone
at you he's going to throw a phone at
you
[Laughter]
yeah say rush
don't [ __ ] he has never ever go to he
did it like one time and he was never
ever going to live that day
they were bad i understand
i probably thrown a phone or you know a
book or something like that in my life
yeah
i'm not known as that book throwing
[ __ ] yeah but uh yeah poor
russell
well he's famous that's why i wrote a
book though
he can throw a phone you know it's all
right he should branch out he could
throw it yeah
but um i don't know why i just even
remember that
but uh yeah so yeah he can throw a phone
played and knocked it out the park i
loved that movie i really liked that
movie thing it was super weird
but um yeah yeah i like all of darren
aronofsky's movies
but um yeah so some people have been
bringing up dracula untold
which yeah it's it's weird because i
feel like like i said the dark universe
was such a [ __ ] great idea it was a
great idea
but i feel like if they were gonna do it
they shouldn't have tried to do it like
let's do it like
marvel like these are like all
superheroes they should have gone in a
more horror direction i think
i think they were trying to but but this
was not a horror movie there was nothing
scary in it really
it's just kind of like it was trying to
be like
an adventure action movie think about
what you're asking though
a real horror movie is going to be r
rated all right yeah and that's a bummer
that's gonna that's that they're they're
not gonna allow that
because that would mean that it you
could not have the widespread appeal
that of the marvel movies and what they
wanted was to do what the marvel
universe did yeah
so you're gonna you're always gonna be
dealing with something kind of like
underworld
or league of extraordinary gentlemen
which i was not a fan of the underworld
movies i wasn't a fan of van helsing
either
i don't like i generally don't like
those kind of horror action hybrids
it seemed like a lot of them started
coming out in the 90s you know what i
mean like
everything's dark and like all these
monsters and they have like kind of
superhero powers and
everybody's got like these slick cool
matrix outfits on and stuff and i was
just kind of like
i don't know they all just seem kind of
samey and this one kind of
gave me that same sort of vibe but not
also okay so so yeah they did dracula
and told in 2014 and i guess
that one i did too a lot of people liked
that one they were they were saying in
the comments that was actually much
better than i was expecting
yeah and uh he's like you know he's
insulting
i showed that the trailer assad and he's
like man it doesn't look that good
but i was looking at that trailer and it
didn't look that good from trailer
either
yeah sometimes sometimes it's hard yeah
that's not the way that movie really
played out to me i didn't remember it
that way
you know what i mean in the trailer they
make it look like the movie
that it isn't you know yeah i liked it
like i said they could yeah
like i said it was a lot better than i
was expecting yeah and they also did one
in 2014 called i frankenstein which i
haven't seen i think james mcavoy is in
it
and um so i feel like they were kind of
trying to launch the [ __ ] with that but
they didn't do as well so there's like
okay well never mind
uh you know we're gonna do the mummy
instead which i think they were working
on back in 2012.
and a couple people um have mentioned in
the comments and i really wanted to
mention this
was that tom cruise got all up in this
[ __ ]
he got final uh cut like and final like
uh say
on all the scriptory rights he got found
so it was essentially they kind of let
him run wild with it crazy and cruising
the [ __ ] out of this
yeah and the thing about it was that
there was supposed to be more mummy in
the movie i wanted more mummy in the
movie yeah he was rad
but he didn't want more mommy in the
movie he wanted more me being an action
star in the movie yeah
you know yeah not good because so like
his ego was kind of getting in the way
of the [ __ ]
the mummy was pretty hot there should
have been way more mummy
yeah there's this movie also has a um
a lot of [ __ ] tomb raider in it
it has a lot of in some ways uh this
sounds kind of weird but [ __ ] queen
of the damned
yeah it reminded me of queen of the day
yeah kind of wrong and it's straight up
though in one of its little subplots it
straight up ripped off
american werewolf in london yeah and it
wasn't even like trying to make it watch
because because why did his friend like
his annoying
like comedic sidekick like the dude gets
killed
and then he keeps coming back like as a
rod like a rotting ghost that only tom
cruise can see
right and i'm like that's exactly like
american world for london
and i didn't okay so that's another
thing one this movie seemed like it was
five movies and
one thing which you know it was kind of
like i said it's watchable
there's an hour of movie missing yeah it
just seems like they're trying to do too
many things they're trying to
set up the universe without
concentrating on making a good mummy
movie you know what i mean so it's kind
of all over the place
and i kind of feel like another thing
too is that
pookie trying to get in no oh i thought
somebody was banging on the door
but um because pookie sometimes like hey
let me in
but uh where was i going with that oh um
yeah so
i don't know i just feel like there was
just too much [ __ ] going on
and also i wasn't real clear
if this is going to be a weird thing to
say because there's like a [ __ ] ton of
exposition
in this like there's just exposition
dumps all over the place
um you know like everyone's backstories
like the mummy's backstory and
everything
but that said i still didn't know what
the [ __ ] her deal was like what her
powers were because some people
she killed him and drained him and then
they kind of came back as zombies right
but then the one dude like the annoying
comedic sidekick got killed but then he
kind of came back as a ghost or
something and then was trying to like
hop
and then she was trying to kill tom
cruise so
she could bring seth the god of death
back through him but so she was going to
stab him with the
dagger thing with the stone in it but
then he did it to himself
anyway yeah yeah but that's what she was
gonna do anyway
so i was like so he's like haha i win
i'm like but that's what she was
supposed to do anyway yeah but it
evidently [ __ ] up it [ __ ] up the
ritual somehow
this is this is the part that i did like
about the movie
is that it did have the balls in the
very end to make tom cruise a monster
although but it yeah set did come
through him but i don't think it went
through him totally
he could well he could still roll it but
the thing about that too is that so
essentially now
he's not the mummy he's set the god of
death
and he's also another jekyll and hyde
character
well you're reading into it too much
you're reading his picture
he always says that yeah he always says
that you're trying to analyze it too
much that's not how
a person with a hundred iq sees the
[ __ ] movie all right they just
and most of these people that are
watching this are between
70 and [ __ ] 110 120 iq well even
they're not over analyzing even they
didn't like the movie so well that's
because
you got a geek culture now where the
smarter ones will sit and re
and analyze the the story and then they
they post their analysis up online
and then it kind of sours it for all the
dumb people the dumb people wouldn't
have noticed that
but when you point it out then they did
then they go oh yeah it sucks so that
that costs hollywood a lot of money
because hollywood was from day one
engineered to entertain dumb people
this goes back to the 1920s they were
said that
you know these people are dumb they'll
watch anything they didn't have tv
so the theater was tv and
uh internet changed a lot of businesses
forever
you just there's no way to reverse it
because the consumer awareness of things
is a lot greater than it was back then
the people that run these studios the
people that come up with these stories
they're not highly intelligent they're
trying to
trying to make something on a template
and in an industry that's very old and
antiquated
it's old people making all the money
right now a lot of them are in their 70s
they don't know what the [ __ ] the people
want they don't understand anything
they can't even they'll put they don't
even really understand what twitter is
as a platform that's who you're dealing
with so
you got a bunch of younger people who
are supposedly the creative types
trying to navigate through a highly
[ __ ] toxic
nest of vipers that backstab each other
for [ __ ] jobs they're trying to
work together to get this [ __ ] made they
know it's a piece of [ __ ] but they can't
say anything they're just trying to get
their paycheck
and that's what hollywood insiders have
have been telling people
you know as of late you know on you on
you on youtube
when they appear as guests that's what
they're actually saying
so there isn't [ __ ] any artistic
craftsmanship in any of this
this is especially the bigger the movie
the bigger the movie is the less
artistic christmas well because the more
people are involved in it
there's more people's visions and it's
watering down
but the thing about it is that when they
decided to scrap the dark universe which
like i said it was kind of a bummer
because i
i liked the the concept i like that idea
and then they but they decided well
we're just going to do kind of
standalone movies and then they did
invisible man which was [ __ ] great
um because they modernized it but they
didn't do it like in a cheesy
like hey it's a big action movie kind of
way they made it more like a
psychological thriller which i thought
was really cool
i don't know it's and it bums me out
because they had they were gonna make a
bride of frankenstein movie after
this one that was supposed to come out
in 2019 and then they were gonna do a
creature from the black lagoon
movie which again would have been cool
but i just i feel like the tone they
were just trying to go to marvel
they were trying to go to action movie
with it and i just wish they had gone
more horror with it
another thing too and i saw somebody
make this um
uh make the make this uh criticism
about the mummy and i was like yeah
maybe that's what it was it's like
that the mummy um what was her name
aminette um
that she seemed more like an alien than
an
ancient mummy you know what i'm saying
it was it was almost kind of more like a
stargate kind of vibe
yeah well that yeah but
i think it would have been cooler if
they'd have gone more like old
egypt and there's another thing too it's
like it wasn't just it wasn't even set
in egypt it was set in iraq and then it
was set in england
yeah and then there was like crusader
nights involved in the whole situation
it was just it was too complicated
they needed to simplify the story there
was too much [ __ ] going on
yeah well it looks like there should
have been maybe two or three movies in
this movie
doesn't it just kind of mash together it
seemed like um
they just kind of wanted to throw
everything in there right i think that
was part of the problem but like i said
this is it was something that was made
by a committee
yeah it was exactly right it was
something that was
mashed together with a bunch of
spectacle and a bunch of
[ __ ] kind of uh bluster you know what
i mean but you noticed it had
a the edit was very it had a tempo to it
and it was trying to go along
same pattern of say like indiana jones
in certain parts and then it would go
along
go along the same patterns of a [ __ ]
marvel
movie you know which actually you guys
you know
i've said this before i pretty much hate
marvel movies i just don't like them
um i'll i can sit there and watch them
and be entertained and as soon as the
movie's over i couldn't tell you what i
just saw
couldn't tell you what happened yeah
it's like i enjoy them when i walk
but they're not well because like i said
big spectacle movies are not really my
thing superhero movies so like i'll
watch them like i said some they're
enjoyable like riding a roller coaster
so
yeah i'm more you know i'm a more horror
movie i like horror movies
so so like i said i kind of wish they
had gone more in an old school
and and the thing about this whole like
monster mash um you know we're putting
all the monsters in a shared universe i
was gonna say well there was already a
series that did that and it was called
penny dreadful
so it's like we don't need to do that
again um
yeah but you can redo things and top
other things you know yeah they don't
look at it that way because
everything that they're doing today was
something that was done over and over
again over a period of about 100 years
just started in the 20s yeah everything
was done they did
everything yeah they were running out of
[ __ ] by the time the 40s was rolling
around
[ __ ] hollywood was recycling old well
and the crazy thing about it
over and over again is and james rolfe
from cinemassacre was pointing this out
because he's
he he's a huge fan of the old universal
monster movies from the 20s and 30s
and he pointed out he's like you know
marvel if anything is ripping off
those universe like for the shared
universe because that's what they used
to be the universal monsters
it was all kind of like they showed up
in each other's movies there was monster
mashes
it was all kind of different [ __ ] so
it's almost kind of like marvel got the
idea from that
and now universal is trying to do it
again which like i said is a cool idea i
just think they didn't go about it the
right way
i thought the look was good uh so we
were getting well that's just a problem
when the mummy's hot no
the mom that that i i really like i like
how she
she looks kick ass i like that character
would have liked more of it
um it was kind of like something out of
queen of the damn
she was started off looking like just a
damn corpse
she was like a vampire too and like a
sorcerer she kind of
so it was that's what i mean it was just
she could do all kind of things i didn't
really know what her power is
trying to do about [ __ ] she was kind of
like a what what were those things
called from blood vessel
um yeah
it's kind of like a stragoi uh she could
do it do a bunch of cool [ __ ]
and um the more people she drank the the
i guess you could say the more complete
she became where she started to look
like she was alive
but she did look supernatural you know
she kind of had
kind of a weird bluish tint and she had
more than one
pupils in each eye yeah um
she had all this inscription tattoos all
over
she never did look totally living though
yeah
um she was a good-looking actress
yeah she was in one of the kingsmen
movies i think that's when why they cast
her for this because she did like a
really physical
yeah she was doing a lot and i think she
was i wanted to start one she was in one
of the star trek movies or one of the
star trek series like one of the new
ones i think
okay and then um but she she you know i
think she's algerian
i thought it was a good character she
looked like nefertiti
yeah you know uh but with like dreads
the long braids remember she had a hair
which you see that on some mummies so
you know i was just
i thought it was cool yeah the look of
her was cool
i just i didn't like i thought i okay i
thought the movie
could have been really good if they one
would have simplified it
don't try to you know establish an
entire cinematic universe in one [ __ ]
movie that's less than two hours long
you know what i mean you're just asking
for trouble
um make it more horror based tell tom
cruise to shut up
he can be in the movie but just chill
out
um and i didn't like i don't know it's
it's almost kind of like i like that
they sort of made his character
a dick um who kind of grows in the end
but and there were actually a couple of
funny lines in it that made me laugh
but a lot of the humor just didn't do it
wasn't that good the humor wasn't that
good it was just kind of like
kind of generic humor not to offend
anybody that you'd put in a big old
[ __ ]
uh tenth hole movie it just well it
didn't work with the i
i just wanted it to be he's not funny he
i wanted it to be scary
yeah now the okay now two times in the
movie i did laugh out loud
the one time was when she was when
what's her face that
that character that his love interest
that probably that needed more screen
time she didn't even
need to be in the movie really because
she didn't have anything to do right but
um which was kind of sad
but uh when she was saying well i know
that you're a good person in there
somewhere because you
gave me the last parachute yeah plane
was crashing um without thinking about
it and then he just looks at her and
goes
i thought there was another one okay so
that was funny
um so that was the only time that he
made me laugh
the other time was when tom cruise
thinks he's gonna go hit the mummy with
like this bat or a stick or something
like that and she just picks it up and
[ __ ] flings him like way up in the
air and then like he fall
so i liked tom cruise getting his ass
kicked in the movie that was hilarious
yeah it gets his ass kicked by a girl
you know that was funny
but um but he yeah he had one line that
made me laugh like the part about the
parachute
yeah and i will say i did like that
sequence where they were in the plane
and it was crashing and they're tumbling
around they did that for real that was
the vomit comet
okay you know what i mean that that's
that plane where they do the parabolic
whatever like to train astronauts or
whatever
so he made them do it for real so they
were all like puking on each other and
whatnot what i thought
the part that i kind of liked was the
idea that uh
first of all that dr jekyll was in
charge of this [ __ ] anti-monster army
all right and uh when he finally does
flip into hyde
he thinks it's a good idea that that the
mummy
uh that the mummy brings set into the
world
yeah and he's like yeah yeah yeah let's
do that
yeah this brings satan into the world
yeah good one
he and i will be real good friends and
that was like a good twist
i was like yeah hyde would want satan to
come into the world you'd think that was
[ __ ] cool
and uh but i liked it you know badger
didn't think that [ __ ] dr jekyll mr
hyde worked i thought it did work i
would like to see a whole movie with
that
well like i think they would if it was
me if somebody
wants to give me started with a movie
about him several million dollars yeah
you know hey i'm right here i'll work
cheap honestly you have to do a [ __ ]
prequel
i'll write a whole dark universe for you
yeah how many
i think it's supposed to be ten minutes
it'll never happen because i know but
i'm just saying
the [ __ ] bags that have all the money
right now it's basically a cartel of
[ __ ] a hundred dudes and they're all
gonna be fighting over a piece of that
goddamn pie
to give it to one person like oh no we
can't have that we can't have that
you know don't do that we need to get me
in there somehow so then you'd be on a
committee of [ __ ] 30 people
all of them saying exactly the opposite
things well even if you did
that's why their [ __ ] sucks even if one
person did write it and it was
awesome and it was all interconnected
and stuff by the time
you know it went through all the hands
oh it'd be [ __ ] up and they'd be like
well can we put this person in there and
can we
can we put in this kind of thing this is
what all the kids are into these days
let's
put some of that in there you know yeah
and and what's funny is that
the people that make these things have
no business sense
whatsoever you know not even basic sales
for every one customer you [ __ ] piss
off you actually piss off 10
because that person turns around and
[ __ ] turns 10 other people off from
you
you never want to [ __ ] divide an
audience you never want to
you never want to insult any anybody
everything has to be
[ __ ] positive all right
somebody in the comment section says
yeah what really sucks
the reason why they're failing now is
because people don't like them because
they know what they think of the
audience and yeah
they don't like you they think you're
[ __ ] stupid all right um
you've got to be stupid you work for
peanuts they don't work for peanuts they
work for [ __ ] millions and millions
of dollars
and they just see themselves as above
you they just they do
especially in that in that town and
they're people that get
kicked out of hollywood will tell you
how [ __ ] rotten those people are
looking that one director said what do
you call him the scum of the earth
what was that director the director from
the me the [ __ ] toxic avenger
that was larry cohen yeah yeah he says
they never pay you they try to rip you
off
well it's funny i was just reading um i
think they just posted it yesterday i
was reading a big long article um
on av club about uh mystery science
theater and they were and they had
interviewed like all of the cast members
and they were talking about
their experience of making mystery
science theater the movie back in 1996
and you know if you don't know anything
about the show they had been making the
show in their own studio in minnesota
and uh then you know they had interest
like to do
a movie version of it so they all had to
go out to la and they're like we really
were not used to
having um all of these people like
interfering
yeah and then having to do because when
they were on comedy central and to
sci-fi to a lesser degree
um the tv execs left them on their own
they're just like whatever just you know
send us a show they didn't [ __ ] with it
um so they're like so we weren't used to
having to like tell tell them all the
jokes
explain all the jokes to them yeah um
sometimes they were like well that
joke's too obscure no one's going to get
it like
you know take it out make sure i'll tell
you what your product's going to be
right right and then so they were like
really offended by that you know what i
mean because they're like um we're
comedians we've been doing this for a
really long time yeah
he's really successful you're not funny
right pretty much and there's like and
you're telling us like how to be funny
and it's just you know
it was like a really disheartening
experience for them yeah um
i mean the movie turned out great i i
have to say i really really like mystery
science theater the movie like it's
still hilarious
even though i know that they had to kind
of generalize
their jokes and then the stupid thing is
that they did this they only gave them
two million dollars to make it
and then when it came out they the
studio put all their money into
a barbed wire that anderson big bomb
and they're basically like well we don't
have any money to market your movie so
it opened in like 12
theaters or something i didn't even see
it in the theater i had to wait till i
came out on dvd
what's funny with mst is that uh
evidently they couldn't get back on
netflix netflix wouldn't buy it
probably because netflix couldn't
control it because it's probably that
same thing
oh no we want to control everything you
do oh no it's got to be this got to be
that
it was like [ __ ] that so they couldn't
get on netflix so they just did a
kickstarter and they
got a [ __ ] ton of money enough to make
at least a season
yeah they're going to make a season they
want to do what joel wants to do is they
want to do
they're building something called the
gizmoplex which is essentially going to
be
i don't i get i guess it's going to be
almost kind of like their own streaming
service where they're going to be able
to have live events they're going to
show their you know
yeah yeah yeah so i think that's what
they're trying to do
i think they're up to four million yeah
a million bucks
yeah and only in a few days and you see
this is the [ __ ]
that makes these executives [ __ ]
tremble
because there are people out there
making money that they want that they
needed
and making that money without them you
don't need them
you don't need him anymore yeah well
that's [ __ ] good and that really
drives them
crazy they're gonna go down and go to
[ __ ] buy a rent out an abandoned mall
and put a damn
studio in there to do mystery science
theater
and do the voice acting and they can it
doesn't cost them anything to do that
not compared to a google studio and
they'll and they'll get to keep all the
profits and have all the controls you
don't even need their platforms
because they already have a fan base
yeah obviously got your own fan base you
don't need them and
and that worries them because they for a
hundred years they've had their [ __ ]
hands and fingers in that pie
and [ __ ] them you know they did it to
themselves
you know what's crazy about going back
to the mummy is that
so this is the movie that you know
[ __ ] up the whole dark universe they
said you okay [ __ ] it we're not doing
that anymore like i said they are still
doing like some standalone ones like
because they did invisible man and stuff
but um even though they went in a
different direction with it
but the fact that the mummy made 410
million dollars
but was still a failure i think it cost
150 million to make but then
all the marketing costs and all that
other kind of [ __ ] so it ended up like
the studio lost like 95 mil on it even
though it made 410 million
i think a lot of it was made overseas um
it was actually pretty successful like
in asia and stuff like that
um i think in some other countries maybe
korea
and uh some parts of europe i think it
was like the best
uh performing tom cruise movie like ever
you know what i'm saying he's trying to
knock the door down is she
come on what's the matter position
hiding something from me she's like what
are you guys scared to walk in oh
poke it's okay baby look at that little
girl
she's such a sweet pea but yeah so the
fact that it can make that much money
and still be a failure
i don't know i just really like like i
said i was watching to send a massacre
about this earlier
like one of their monster madness shows
from a couple years ago no
and i'm getting clogged yeah cool you
might want to close that up well i don't
think she can open it she's not strong
enough
um but he was saying because like i said
you know james rolfe is kind of like
he's really into like old movies and he
really likes like the old universal like
black and white movies
and he's like i almost he's like if i
had you know the money
he's like i would love to see like a
universal monster movie i want more
movies
in black and white like that but modern
you know what i mean but like still do
them in the same style as though it was
like continuing
and i was like see now i know that's not
because he's like the thing is you can't
make
he's like these kind of movies have to
be made kind of niche you can't do them
like
a [ __ ] marvel universe it just seems
like it would be better
like like what they did with invisible
man just like make it
a cheaper movie but you know i mean and
don't try to like link them all up maybe
you know i don't know i kind of like the
idea of linking them all up
but i don't know it it just seems like i
don't know it's
too convoluted yeah well here's another
thing
i i think a lot a lot of the younger
generations are kind of
pre-programmed for this universe idea
but i don't think film is the future of
that it would be these series
well like i said they've done series
like that because penny dreadful is kind
of like that that you know that has um
the aesthetic qualities of
dreddy penny dreadful in this movie
though are very different
yeah it's a different thing very very
different but like i said i'm more into
uh you know the penny dreadful type of
thing than
the i don't know it's like the movie
like the mummy it just seemed it wasn't
a bad movie it just seemed very generic
to me yeah
exactly badger's in there saying you
know he lost all his [ __ ] time
watching this [ __ ] he was crying
about it when it was over i don't look
at it that way because i never took the
movie to sirius to begin with i don't
know if it was if he was talking about
this movie or maybe he was talking about
another one
because this particular movie i was
expecting like a total dumpster fire
because that's what i heard about it
um so i had my expectations were very
low so i just
watched it and just [ __ ] wrote it
like a roller coaster it didn't have a
whole lot of content
it was just something to watch and yeah
that's
and those kind of movies traditionally
did pretty well
because people are going into the
theater disengaging their [ __ ]
thinking process
and just laying back and pretending you
know expecting to be entertained
and like i said the average person in
that theater is not that intelligent
they'll just go along with it
and this did have some entertaining
advertising to it
like the look of it was cool yeah there
was some cool i just like i said i don't
cool statues and [ __ ] in the caves and
it wasn't very
engaging you didn't really have to
mentally engage with the movie you could
just look at it
and i had a good time yeah you could
just yeah you could just look at it
and the thing about it is like there was
some characters like i said that were
really underdeveloped
they didn't even need to be there like
his comic sidekick
i mean they were giving tom cruise like
some jokes like he was supposed to be
like wisecracking and [ __ ] like that so
why did you need like the funny guy he
didn't even need to be in there
they could have just written him out uh
the girlfriend
she needed to be her character really
needed to be more
uh like written more about her because
she didn't do anything
she didn't really didn't need to be in
the movie either like other than being
the impetus for tom cruise to be
being slightly less of a dick you know
yeah um
that's kind of the only reason she was
in there and um
you know so she didn't really do
anything other than that which was a
shame
but i don't know it's and it just seemed
like there was i don't know there was
just too much [ __ ] going on there's too
much [ __ ] going on
they needed to simplify simplify
simplify they're talking about the
the new star trek in quotations i laugh
at that [ __ ] too
the movies and uh i've heard about
discovery i i won't watch it i just
evidently they say star trek discovery
is like a really good source
for like uh if if you have a [ __ ]
youtube show
about sci-fi you know or entertainment
that series right there's a real good
source of rifts
you could just riff on that [ __ ] all day
long it's supposed to be just absolutely
ridiculous
and they got whole youtubers making a
damn career off of
making fun of the new star trek it's not
stop it pope that's male
1 that's me she did you see she looked
over her shoulder and went right back to
it no i'm gonna tear it up
that's male no she doesn't care what
daddy says daddy daddy can yell at her
all day long and she just stops for a
minute goes
you done yelling okay yeah she wants me
to go over there and wrestle with her
well yeah she wants okay she wants to
get in trouble get so
quote punished she wants to get in
trouble
okay yeah yeah you're in trouble well
you know any attention is good attention
yeah that's what she figured she's
she's like a little she's just waiting
for this [ __ ] to happen she's not she's
not all that bratty
yeah she's mostly a good girl she just
likes attention that's all
but evidently it's like a new star trek
i saw the star trek movies i think the
first
two of the new ones those were all right
they were just okay but i'm like this
isn't really star trek
you know i mean i liked him at the time
like i don't know if i'd watch them
again but i had fun with them now
there's a lot of difference between that
and [ __ ] real star trek i mean if you
want to [ __ ] if you like star trek
you watch the original series
and then you watch [ __ ] star trek
continues which is just like the
television series with the old
i mean it's kind of hard to beat the
original series oh hey you know
i just i just love all that i just love
that 60s aesthetic you know i mean
so even that makes more sense to me yeah
even the more recent ones i was just
kind of like you know they're
fine but i i just always go back to the
original series i never get tired of
like watching
those star trek the motion picture
rather con and that whole thing i liked
those too yeah even though like it was
the undiscovered country was
kind of sucky and we i think we watched
all of the movies
like a few months ago i think we watched
them all like over a few weeks i gotta
[ __ ] say man i go back to
you can say well rather khan's the best
one but star trek the motion picture was
pretty good too
yeah although i just don't think
wrathicon is the best one
the motion picture was good because
half of that [ __ ] was gonna be something
called star trek phase two i think it's
called phase two
which was a television series and uh
the guy who was supposed to be the
captain that [ __ ] captain kirk knocks
out of the way who ends up [ __ ]
leaving with vegeta and [ __ ] he was
going to be the captain of the new star
trek series
yeah okay television series yeah but
they
evidently canceled the television series
and made fun
and made the movie instead and then
later on some of the stuff that they
were going to use in the television
series ended up on next generation
yeah okay but uh
now just watch look in the original
series and see uh star trek continues
that's the that's the final
season to the original show with old vic
vic mignona as [ __ ] captain kirk he
does a good job
todd haberkorn as [ __ ] as uh
what's his name spock he's a little bit
different but
he does a good spot and and the guy
playing scotty is scotty's real son the
guy who deforest kelly's real son
real son yeah and i've got a lot of the
same people who worked on the original
series did it
and it's in the old format just like the
original television series
all the way down to kind of like the
hokey [ __ ] kung fu
well yeah they wanted it to be as close
to the original area
they wanted the same lighting the same
sets the same costumes the same tone the
same everything
got one of the best mirror mirror
episodes out of the whole [ __ ]
all the star trek that was the one where
what what did
mirror kirk do excuse me what did mirror
spock do
once [ __ ] hit when he got when he got
his captain back
what happened to the uh to his rebellion
did he do it because yeah he did do it
so it was good it was that's a good
episode yeah
i think it was called what was it called
fairest of them all yeah that's right i
think it was
yeah yeah if you want to see if you want
to start uh if you want to start the uh
if you want to start [ __ ] um look at
pokey yeah i know
she's disgraceful i want to start with
with with the offshoot when
you see ferris have them all uh first
it's on youtube
for free in hd it's good
but uh that's probably about it on this
huh yeah i think so
jenny didn't like it i liked it but i
didn't expect anything it was just
just done i didn't expect it wasn't as
bad as i was expecting yeah
i'll say that big dumb over top action
movie it had
something it had its moments and like i
said i liked
the look of the mummy i like but i just
kind of i wish that they had done more
of like a traditional mummy story
and more like a scary horror movie they
could have some action [ __ ] in there too
if they
like absolutely had to but like i said
they already made
like a fun adventure mummy movie with
brendan fraser back in 1999. it's like
we can just watch that they don't need
to do that again
you know that wasn't their money they
wanted they wanted to make their own
money
i guess so but it's just i don't know
looking at it from their
perspective and i just feel like if
you're gonna do
like i said i'm not averse to the idea
of doing a dark universe or doing
like the a universal monsters you know
universe i think that's kind of a cool
idea
but if you're gonna do it you really
need like a writer or just a group of
writers
that kind of map out the whole thing and
i think that they should have they can
have their own kind of
you know feel to them because they're
all different monsters but i feel like
you need to work all that [ __ ] out work
the tone out
work the [ __ ] look out so they're all
kind of cohesive
and they all kind of like hang together
the problem is is that all these
properties are owned by
studios that are very corrupt money
hungry and it's always going to be made
by a committee and it will always be
yeah
i know the best thing to do is instead
of trying to recapture
these old classics and [ __ ] bring
them back to life and all that [ __ ]
theoretical crazy crap is to make
brand new [ __ ] that's good well honestly
that it's small like one yeah person can
control with his team
just like mst did yeah it'd be something
like that
you're gonna make these monster movies
and you're gonna make your own universe
and you got your own [ __ ] fan base
well yeah i mean honestly the best
horror movies that i've seen in the past
few years have been
standalone yeah indy horror movies
well it's getting to the point now where
eventually you're going to have like you
know the dude who did
does mandalorian what's that guy's name
guys trying to say john favreau
john probably he could if he owned his
own
property he could say [ __ ] disney i'm
going to [ __ ] build my own studio and
uh i'm gonna make my own space adventure
and
people would probably watch it he says i
could do better than star wars
he could probably he probably could and
it had the same tone and everything
yeah with that without it not being a
knockoff i mean like i said
i understand you know studios are just
trying to make money and they don't
and they don't actually know what people
want so they're just kind of like
throwing everything at the wall
and so they try to stick with things
that are safe yeah which you know that's
understandable why they do that
it's not their money they don't want to
take a chance on something that might
not do well they want something with
name recognition yeah
that's why holders and all this [ __ ]
involved well the thing about it too is
that i know a lot of people complain
about oh sequel this and reboot that but
it's like well
they're still making money that's why
they're still doing them so if you don't
want them to make them then don't go see
them and they won't make them anymore if
you look at star trek continues for free
on youtube
you will see what i'm talking about how
a small group of people if they can
raise their own money and make a quality
show
that [ __ ] and it had very there were
no corporate fingers involved in that
because it was non-profit
yeah well if you owned your own property
you could do that again
all right and have your own [ __ ] your
own version of a space opera
and and you could beat star trek and you
could beat star wars
people keep trying to go back on this
old ship [ __ ] that [ __ ]
it's played out it's it's owned by bad
people you got to make new [ __ ]
make a new [ __ ] is this is the key yeah
just make a whole i know
i know it's harder it's you know because
you don't have like i said you don't
have name recognition
yeah but the name recognition has to go
for to like the the writers and the and
the directors that
like a team like a studio has to have
some kind of a little small
mom pop studio type deal you know what i
mean
like what you said jean-paul bros that
guy's name yeah five row imagine if he
said [ __ ] it i'm gonna make my own
studio
i'm i i want to make this new space
opera hit me up on kickstarter he'd get
millions and millions of dollars oh i'm
sure he would
yeah and he would have to deal with the
knees of [ __ ] yeah
yeah well like you said it's much easier
nowadays you can make your own [ __ ] and
and honestly most
99 of the really great horror movies
i've seen the last
several years have been indie i mean
there's been a couple like i said
invisible man was great but um
you know what i mean which which is
universal but mostly
they've been ending movies i've been
yeah looking that that that
that last [ __ ] um [ __ ] what's that
dude
mandy yeah you know that movie was great
that dude's a crazy person that makes
those movies
[Laughter]
like in the best possible way and then
um then we uh [ __ ] what's yeah
what's that crazy [ __ ] that
started mandy man
nicholas yeah and then we saw that other
nicholas cage movie that was an indie
where he didn't say a goddamn word to
the whole thing willie's wonderland
willie's wonderland
it was a great movie that was bad [ __ ]
insane that was something that
had i seen that back in on you know like
on on cable or something back in the 80s
that would have been one of my favorites
that's oh yeah
that's some bad ass [ __ ] yeah it was
[ __ ] hilarious yeah i love
weird honestly i would rather if you
were going to make a movie i would
rather you made a weird ass
movie that failed yeah then try to make
something to please everybody because
you're never going
to yeah and the more generic you make it
the more bland and boring it gets
just go lean into the weirdness it might
you might not succeed but at least you
made something interesting
yeah nothing that they're trying to do
is they're trying to um do something
with these old superhero
[ __ ] names you know to mimic marvel
you need to make new superheroes like
you know bright burn
that's [ __ ] pretty cool man that
wasn't a superhero super villain you
know yeah
and um i thought that did i feel like we
need more villain movies yeah
villains are more interesting than
heroes if i was gonna make a star wars
movie
it would be a darth vader movie yeah
we've so yeah we've talked about that
before
i would totally be the main character
and trying to get out from underneath
control of the emperor
find a sith holocrons going into sith
tombs learning about
old sith that were around him before
like darth revan and [ __ ] these dudes
from knights of the old republic the old
that's the kind of [ __ ] where he goes to
korraban if you guys know what i'm
talking about yeah
see that yeah i don't i'd watch that
yeah and he can't really betray the
emperor because the emperor is [ __ ]
keeping him alive through some kind of
force some kind of force power
he was resurrected by the emperor and
was kept alive so
he has to be loyal or or the [ __ ]
emperor will stop feeding him that force
juice and he dies
forced juice forward we all need forced
juice yeah he's keeping him alive with
that for
forced testosterone
yeah you just knew the show couldn't go
by without you
mentioning it look we gotta go well i
gotta go pick it up
that's right we gotta we gotta go buy
there the man
he laughs every time he sees it on my
phone then it says man clinical
i'm like what else am i supposed to call
it yeah but yeah yeah we got to do that
and we got to run to the post office too
we got to put gas in the car because we
i forgot we were coming back from
downtown last night i was like oh yeah
my [ __ ] car's on e probably i should
put some gas in the car
but uh you know i don't use it all that
much pokey what the hell are you doing
yeah fourth row down says so nicholas
cage accidentally made the best horror
movies for the last 10 years he did
yes well i love like i said i love that
hilt one he'll be in anything
because he needs the money yeah and he
if he's gonna be in something like he'll
[ __ ] commit
and he'll just like act [ __ ] crazy
and that's why you hire nicholas cage
it's like
just cage the [ __ ] out and he's just
like can do
yeah here's your paycheck mr cage you
know what i mean it doesn't always work
but uh you know color out of space that
was [ __ ] great
mandy was [ __ ] great yeah willie's
wonderland was great and i love that he
didn't even talk in it that just like
cracked me up that made it even better
it did yeah i don't know i know some
people didn't like that but i was just
kind of like no man that was like that
was [ __ ]
that was just like one joke that just
sustained me through the whole [ __ ]
thing it was just funny is that like
that
pat says i'd love to see the other
characters out of the bright burn
universe yeah we were just talking about
the other day
yeah evil spider-man imagine that evil
punisher
or eve or more evil punisher i guess
you could say that was dc big evil
batman yeah
batman punisher real similar they are
kind of yeah they're both kind of
vigilantes
yeah i think i think i heard my phone go
off maybe that was that okay maybe that
might have been the doctor's might be
all right all right so thanks you guys
for dropping by as always man we were on
for like almost an hour
so um yeah he did make a great hormone
yeah colorado space was awesome yeah
um yeah it was mixed people peop some
people didn't like it but i liked it
i liked it yeah yeah like i said if
you're gonna make a movie like that just
make it weird
and put [ __ ] nick cage in that [ __ ]
yeah i mean because you know he's gonna
[ __ ] give it his all it's the mark of
the dude's got [ __ ]
taxes to pay that's right all right
so uh we will be back tomorrow evening
at 5 00 p.m eastern for our wednesday
drunken party stream
yeah we know you guys love those we love
those we have a good time talking to you
guys yeah that's tomorrow night
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] man my [ __ ] kitties okay
you're what
kidneys oh your candies i was like your
kidneys what about your kidneys
all right so we'll see you guys tomorrow
evening
have a good rest of your day bye